لم تتغير غرفة النوم منذ أن
تركوا حيوانات محشوة على السرير ،
ملابسهم في الخزانة ،
لن تغيرها جدتهم ، وتقول إنها لا تزال تنبعث
منها رائحة مثلهم في Cielo و Newsela الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 8
و 7 سنوات غادروا منزلهم في كازاخستان
للذهاب إلى الصين  مع والدتهم بشكل أعمق
في عام 2017 ، نشأ تصحيح في الصين ، لذا
عادت في زيارة قصيرة لرؤية بعض
أفراد العائلة وتأخذ بعض الدروس في
شينجيانغ في شمال غرب الصين
، ظل زوجها ييست وابنها الصغير نورما كين في
المنزل ولكن بعد وقت قصير من وصولهما
اختفت ديبا وابنتها
لأنهما عادا في الوقت الخطأ ،
شين جانغ هي المنطقة التي تقول الولايات المتحدة
إن الصين وضعت فيها ما يصل إلى مليوني
شخص تقريبًا كل المسلمين في
معسكرات اعتقال على مدار السنوات القليلة الماضية ،
يقول نشطاء إن بكين فعلت ذلك
لمحاولة  للقضاء على الإسلام داخل
حدودها ، أخبر معتقلون سابقون شبكة CNN
أنهم تعرضوا للتعذيب في الداخل أثناء
خضوعهم لوذمة التلقين
السياسي وعائلتها مسلمة
زوجها نعم تان يقول أحد أقاربها قال مرحباً
تم وضع زوجته في مثل هذا المخيم بينما
تم إرسال بناته للعيش مع
أقارب بعيدين لم يسمع
أي منهم منذ ما يقرب من عامين عندما
رأى شابات في الحي
يسميهن ماما نعم يقول إنه لا يفعل ذلك.  لا
أعرف حتى ما تبدو عليه والدته ،
وتقول الصين إن هذه المعسكرات ليست سجونًا
ولكنها مراكز تدريب مهني
تطوعية تُستخدم ليس
للقضاء على الإسلام بشكل عام فقط التطرف الإسلامي ،
لكن الحكومة ربطت
بالهجمات الإرهابية السابقة في المنطقة ، لذلك
تمارس السلطات الدعاية.  مقاطع فيديو مثل
هذه على التلفزيون الذي تديره الدولة لإظهار
المسلمين السعداء وهم يتعلمون بمرح أنهم
يقابلون بعض الذين يُفترض أنه تم
إصلاح اقتباساتهم ، ابتعدوا عن
حياة الإرهاب ولكن حتى لو كان هذا صحيحًا ، نعم
10 يقول هذا لا يزال لا يفسر سبب
حبس زوجته  زوجتي ليست
إرهابية يقول إنها لا علاقة
لها بها ولا يمكنني التعبير بكلمات عن
مقدار الألم الذي أشعر به عندما أفكر بها
هناك ،
سألنا السلطات الصينية عن ماذا
حدث
Madiba أنهم لم يردوا على
سؤالنا ، لذلك ذهبنا إلى Shin Jang
بأنفسنا إلى بعض المناطق
النائية في الصين وسافرنا آلاف
الأميال في كل ما ذهبنا إلى ستة أماكن
لمعرفة ما يحدث هنا وفي
بلدة واحدة لمحاولة  العثور على ديبا
أقليات مسلمة عرقية تعيش هنا منذ
قرون ، نحن غير القوزاق وغيرهم ،
متميزين ثقافيًا عن الهان الصينيين
الذين يهيمنون على بقية البلاد ،
لكنهم الآن مجبرون على إثبات
أنهم لا يشكلون تهديدًا لكاميرات الدولة.
كل تحركاتهم في بعض
الأماكن المتمركزة كل 50 مترًا بينما يتنقل
الهان الصينيون بانتظام عبر
حواجز الشرطة التي لا تعد ولا تحصى ، أي شخص رأيناه
يبدو أنه أقلية تم
إيقاف التنميط العنصري يبدو متفشيًا ،
لكن كل ذلك لا يزال على الأرجح أفضل من
حياة أولئك الذين ينتهي بهم المطاف في  أماكن
مثل معسكرات الاعتقال هذه المصممة
للأقليات العرقية المسلمة مثل هذا الموجود
خارج مدينة كاشغر
بدا لنا كثيرًا ما تسميه الصين موقعًا للتدريب على الوظائف
أشبه بجدران عالية
لأبراج حراسة من الأسلاك الشائكة في السجن ، أشياء قال العديد من
الخبراء لشبكة CNN إنها علامات منبهة
لمراكز الاحتجاز صور مثل هذه
نادرًا ما شاهدها القليل من الناس مثل
هذه المعسكرات عن قرب لأن حكومة الصين
تحاول منع المراسلين مثلنا من
رؤيتهم ضابط شرطة  سرعان ما
ذكرنا بهذه الحقيقة ، ما
يحدث هنا هو أن ضابط الشرطة هذا
لا يريدنا أن نصور ، لكن
ما نعتقد أنه
معسكر هناك هو أقرب ما
تمكنا من الوصول إليه وهناك
نعتقد أن عائلتنا  من
المفترض أن يكون لديهم أفراد من العائلة داخل
هذا المعسكر وينتظرون
لرؤيتهم تقول الصين إنه ليس لديها ما تخفيه
هنا ، لكنهم لا يعرقلون
محاولات التصوير أو الدخول إلى المخيم فحسب ،
بل يمنعوننا أيضًا من التحدث إلى
أولئك الذين  تعرف أي شيء عنهم
حاولنا التحدث إلى هذا الرجل الذي
جلب الطعام لأخيه الذي يقول
إنه محتجز في المخيم ولكن قبل
أن نتمكن من السؤال عن الحياة داخل
أحاطت بنا ملابس الأمن وأخبرنا الرجل
أن يكون هادئًا ، فهناك معسكرات مثل هذه في
جميع أنحاء شين جانغ على بعد 1000 ميل
تقريبًا ، أخذنا قطارًا إلى مدينة
توربان لنرى
نوعًا آخر من السجون مثل الجدران نفس النوع من
السرية وفي الدقيقة التالية  وصلت إلى
نفس النوع من مضايقات الشرطة سيدتي ،
هل يمكنك أن تخبرني ما هذا هذا
الشيء الذي لا تريدنا أن نرى
لماذا كنت هنا نحن هنا لتصوير
ما نعتقد أنه معسكر لنا نحن
جيرس وخا  'zix وللأطفال
ولكل الأقليات العرقية المسلمة ،
هددت باعتقالنا وطالبتنا
بحذف لقطاتنا ، لذا اضطررنا إلى مغادرة
محطتنا الأخيرة وهي بلدة trollee
حيث تقول عائلة المغنية إنها
احتجزت زوجها ، نعم لم أصدق
تم السماح لها منذ ذلك الحين بالخروج من
المخيم وعادت لتعيش مع
بناتها ، وقد تم إخبار yeste أنهم لا يستطيعون مغادرة
الصين لأن المسؤولين أخذوا
جواز سفر المغنية ليس لديه طريقة للاتصال
بها ويخشى أن ينتهي به الأمر في المخيم
بنفسه  إذا ذهب إلى الزعنفة  لقد
حاولنا العثور على ديبا بأنفسنا ، ولكن
بمجرد وصولنا إلى المدينة ، أغلقت
شرطة المرور طريقنا وأصر المسؤولون الذين
كانوا يتابعوننا على عشاء جماعي
رفضنا بشدة قول لا لا
لا ، لكننا في النهاية  لم يكن أمامنا أي
خيار لأن الأقليات المسلمة تعيش في
معسكرات ليست بعيدة حيث
يشرب المسؤولون الحكوميون الخمور
ويرقصون على الموسيقى الشعبية ، إنه مشهد سخيف
ولكن لا يمكننا المغادرة وبالتالي لم
نتمكن من العثور على مغنية ولم نتمكن من
تقديم هذا  رسالة ما نعم tanaan
tadesse لمشاركتها إذا وجدناها اقتبس من
ابننا وكنت
أنتظر وسننتظرك دائمًا أنت
حب حياتي الأنهار مات سي إن إن شين
جيانغ الصين